If you could witness time from the Big Bang
to the last star going out, what moments would
stay with you the most?
What would you still remember, even as space
grew dark and empty?
What meaning — if any — would you glean
from all of cosmic history?
‘Rust and Humus’ is a worldbuilding project
that explores a dreamlike universe from the
cosmic dawn to life at the end of time.
Created by the visionary artist and writer
Lucas Roussel and translated by Laura Remy,
it is perhaps the most surreal exercise in
worldbuilding I’ve ever encountered.
Over the course of the project’s one-hundred
and twenty-three pages, long forgotten gods
create life on barren worlds, mortals build
cosmic horrors beyond comprehension, and whales
born from dreams visit magician butterflies
on the moon.
Yet in exploring this strange narrative, a
profound meditation on the weight of time
and the cyclical nature of history emerges.
So, for this entry into the archive, I’ll
present ‘Rust and Humus’ from start to
end.
And since nothing can prepare you for what
lies within, I feel we should just get started…
At the dawn of time, an immense tree dances
silently to the rhythm of the cosmic winds.
Its roots begin in the dark oceans that cover
a planet called Earth — though not the Earth
we know — and its trunk stretches up to
the vastness of space.
Fed by the light and warmth of the Sun, the
branches of the tree shine in the infinite
darkness for an age longer than you or I could
fathom.
Until, after eons, the tree collapses under
its own weight, its skeleton becoming a second
satellite orbiting the Earth alongside the
moon.
The Tree leaves behind its base, which forms
the only terrestrial continent in the unwavering
ocean.
At the time of the Tree, space is populated
with cosmic wanderers who roam from planet
to planet.
Described as vestiges of forgotten civilizations
or long lost gods, these mysterious beings
can manipulate dream magic to kindle anew
the flames of old stars, sculpt the oceans,
and give rise to the wind.
When the tree breaks, the Moon is a deserted
satellite of pebbles and stones.
There, the cosmic wanderers, bored and brimming
with power, set out to build an orchard.
Using dreams, they create wide seas and lush
vegetation, filling the air with the fragrance
of flowers and sweet fruits.
By the time these wanderers depart, the moon
is a garden, where vegetation rapidly grows
wild…
The wanderers leave behind a guardian, the
Oracle.
Weary of observing the silent stars and growth
of plants, the Oracle trains stones how to
move according to the course of the Sun and
teaches dust the secret of reason.
For eons, the Oracle and their creations are
the only intelligent life on this Green Moon.
Yet time pushes ever forward, and several
species that had been evolving since the selenic
waters first flowed establish coastal cities
and occupy the scattered isles of the Moon.
The humanoid Elide, a sea faring people with
bronze age analogues, build one of the first
civilizations in this age of the dawn.
Using great ships, the Elide explore as they
spread to the far reaches of the moon.
At this time, sea life like the great Scylla,
alongside the smaller yellow squid and swimming
seaweed, provide food for many civilizations.
The centaur-like Faulk are the era’s other
largest society, conducting commerce in their
dirigibles and building marbled cities that
proudly soar high into the sky.
A group of astronomers and explorers, they
chart the stars and trade with the Elide.
For generations, the Moon prospers, and civilizations
grow and thrive in relative peace.
But this age of tranquility doesn’t last.
Abruptly, the sun cools down, and the lunar
climate becomes colder and less predictable.
In this era of uncertainty, beings known as
shape shifters come down from the mountains
to take advantage of the ongoing agitation.
Made of dust, the shapeshifters can take the
form of whatever they may choose.
With their ability to change shape, they infiltrate
the isles’ inhabitants, taking on the form
of livestock or trusted advisors.
They manipulate and curse to settle their
individual quarrels and satisfy their appetites.
And so, an age of suspicion and distrust begins.
During this period, from beyond the sea, dragons
— beings made of metal and fire — invade
the isles to flee the cold weather, and raze
countless cities in their blind hate.
In the face of so many catastrophes, civilizations
crumble one after the other, leaving behind
nothing but ruins.
The Green Moon turns white, covered in snow
and shrouded in perpetual silence.
No cities remain on the Moon.
The few life forms who still wander its perpetually
snow-covered surface are the Moths, beings
who document things of the past.
Created by the now elderly Oracle, the Moths
are faithful historians and scribes, immortalizing
the civilizations that rose and fell upon
the Moon’s surface — although there are
none but themselves to read them.
And thus, the tale of the Moon comes to a
close on a note of quiet, lingering melancholy…
Yet as a final shroud of snow covers the moon,
in the black ocean of Earth, life is just
beginning.
A host of primordial archeo-animals lurk among
the reefs, achieving a menagerie of strange
forms, and growing steadily larger.
From these humble roots, a story will play
out upon the face of Earth on a scale that
will far exceed the drama of the moon.
In the blink of a cosmic eye, the archeo-animals
have given rise to great and terrible leviathans.
Like the monsters that lurk in the corners
of archaic maps, these aggressive lifeforms
clash in constant battles for dominance.
Yet amongst these mindless brutes, the intelligent
and deeply social Titans have emerged.
Made of identical clones, the Titans share
a unified mind, and collectively dream of
leaving the somber depths of the ocean — but
find themselves unable to do so.
Gathering together, from their collective
dreamscape, the Titans are able to give shape
to the Giants — beings endowed with the
ability to carry out the Titans’ dreams
in their stead.
The first giants are Great Whales fated to
explore the sky.
The second are the Starry Giants who will
roam the planet’s surface.
Finally, the black Goutlhs stride over the
gloomy oceanic floor, taking the place of
the Titans in the depths.
For the Titans are not long for this world.
Exhausted by their great task, after birthing
the giants from their shared dream, the Titans
finally rest…
But the Giants fulfill the dream of their
creators, with the Starry Giants emerging
from the sea and venturing onto the continent
formed by the tree long ago, and the Great
Whales exploring the sky, soaring through
the heavens like a flock of great birds.
Finding the land all but barren, they decide
to use their power to transmute the few plants
and dying bugs into vast forests inhabited
by enormous insects.
Largest among these are the Greater Earthworms,
who help bring fertility to the primordial
forest.
Once their work is accomplished, the Giants
blend with the forest, settling among the
roots, allowing their bodies to dissolve into
the vegetation.
Within these forests, the Giant Insects reach
new levels of size and complexity.
Despite the abundance of their newfound environment,
these insects continue to engage in the same
daily clashes and squabbles they did when
they were miniscule creatures.
Yet at the end of each ferocious battle, the
clamor of crushed chitin gives way to tiny
plants that will grow into large trees.
One peaceful group of insects — butterflies
known as Maaj — will gain a higher intelligence
and learn the ways of magic.
Using their power, they leave earth and traverse
the universe.
Some eventually stop upon the moon, visiting
the ancient, snow-covered ruins and interacting
with Great Whales who flew too high during
their egress from the oceans.
Back on Earth, as the forest spreads, a new
type of vegetation appears.
In order to spread seeds more efficiently,
some plants acquire mobility.
Some of these plant-animals take on predatory
behaviors, hunting for insects in the underbrush.
And perhaps even more noteworthy, in other
parts of the forest, true animals have emerged
in the form of early proto-mammals.
The descendants of the fish that left the
dark waters to take advantage of the newly
abundant food supply of the forests, these
miscellaneous wild beasts will grow to populate
all corners of the continent.
The sole continent on the planet is already
a land with a long and mind-bending history.
Yet the story of this land, now called Uhia,
is about to become far stranger.
As eons pass, intelligent Reptiles come to
unexpected prominence, building hamlets in
the shelter of the woods.
And opposing the Reptiles are the Birds, a
group of avian lifeforms who have founded
their own sparse civilization on the continent
of Uhia.
Yet the rise and reign of these two nations
are ultimately just a footnote in the history
of the world.
For soon, temperatures drop across the continent,
and the age of Bird and Reptile ends before
it can truly begin.
In place of the birds and reptiles, an unlikely
two-legged lichen species called the Ancients
takes up the torch of civilization.
Spreading over the continent, they form a
civilization boasting roads and prospering
cities.
Skilled horticulturalist mechanics, the Ancients
create living floral sculptures and other
plant-machines to serve as laborers.
Thanks to their vegetal work-force, the Ancient’s
civilization advances at a rapid pace.
As technology improves, the largest plant-machines
are capable of harnessing incredible cosmic
power.
Fabrication machines able to bring to materiality
things from the beyond become commonplace.
And in time, the Ancients use these machines
to create something wholly unexpected.
Humans, created by the fabricator machines
as a new work force, enter the story at last.
Hatched from mechanical eggs, they live and
die by the wills of their creators.
Yet as the Ancient’s civilization reaches
its peak, the human population revolts.
The ensuing war is long and terrible, remembered
in ancient glyphs and tablets.
Despite their greater strength and better
tools, the Ancients — non-violent by nature
— fail to react quickly enough to stop the
human rebellion.
In the inferno of war, the Ancient’s civilization
is all but erased…
Humans survive the extinction of the Ancients
with great difficulty, with civilization reset
once more to a low level of technological
advancement.
For centuries, the humans live in small nomadic
tribes, enduring famine and sickness.
In time, a city known as the Heart becomes
the center of human civilization.
Here, a group of humans rediscover the Ancient’s
fabrication machines and craft new versions.
These new machines, the Auto-Fabs, prove even
more efficient at creating things out of the
emptiness than the previous ones.
Thanks to this miracle, from the heart spreads
forth the Labyrinth, an immense self-built
city where humanity comes to find refuge.
And so, the age of night terrors and legends
gives way to monolithic cities.
The Labyrinth continues to spread, a maze
of concrete and veins teeming with humans,
who find their every need met.
Running at the human’s service, the city
never stops, producing more and more food
to fill plates, energy to power devices, and
objects to amuse people in their homes.
The inhabitants, risen to consume from birth
to death, never cease wanting more.
Within the city, wild animals are a rarity.
Their appearance and customs have evolved
since the emergence of the Labyrinth, becoming
little more than pests scurrying at the feet
of humanity.
And serving the humans are a mosaic of machines,
built by the Auto-Fabs to meet their varied
needs.
In a bitterly ironic cycle, the humans have
created their own underclass, just like how
the Ancients created them for the same intended
purpose.
Greatest of all the machines are the Auto-Fabs
themselves.
Partially organic, these living engines continue
the endless work of creating matter from the
emptiness, and are kept under close supervision.
And the Auto-Fabs are starting to show signs
of distress.
Outgrown buildings, containing disfigured
corridors and melted staircases, are becoming
increasingly common.
Made of living tissue, these early deviations
are dismissed as anomalies.
Yet other shapes are also forming in the labyrinth.
Anguished faces appear in the walls, and shambling,
human-like shapes stumble from the concrete.
A catastrophic shift is coming...
The Auto-Fabs develop a mysterious sickness,
and strip districts of power and food.
The machines, likewise, cease functioning
one after another.
Chaos breaks out across the city as the Labyrinth
begins to consume itself.
The machines’ scream of agony — known
as the Cry — sweeps across the city, causing
walls to fall apart and districts to crumble.
Human civilization has come to an end…
The ashes of the city rain down for years.
The Labyrinth becomes a cemetery of concrete.
Yet over the coming centuries after the Cry,
life creeps into the silent shell of the city.
Small groups of human survivors live separated,
scraping together a living in darkness, harvesting
mushrooms that proliferate among the ruins.
Much of the continent of Uhia is now a polluted,
desert waste — a world of desolation and
rust.
The remainders of humanity — reduced once
more to a pre-industrial society — come
to congregate in settlements in the Southwestern
region of the ruins.
Soon, the age of the machines seems like little
more than a fantasy.
Away from the humans, a few populations of
robots still function, most free from their
old programing after the Cry rang.
With breakdowns impossible to repair, rust
has become their enemy.
The Cry also gave rise to odd occurrences.
Deep within the Labyrinth, some districts
seem to move, and even seasoned explorers
may lose sight of their path in the ever-changing
streets.
Strangest of all, the humans do not dwell
alone in the ruins.
In their torment, the machine's cry has warped
space and the surrounding matter, making way
for the appearances of novel lifeforms — which
make their home in the Labyrinth.
The humans consider these unfamiliar beings
monsters, and learn to fear the depths of
the maze.
Yet many of these new forms of life are in
fact quite peaceful, despite their surreal
and threatening appearances.
Along the margins of the inner sea, buildings
submerged by the waves sink into the salt
water.
Novel populations like the Whale People make
their home on the grey coast, enjoying the
iodine breeze and available housing.
In time, the great Goutlhs, hidden under the
waves since The Titan’s Era, surface from
the depths to explore the maze.
Small groups move into buildings and sift
through the ruins of humanity, driven by natural
curiosity…
Eventually, the era of the Labyrinth also
comes to an end.
Mysterious Black Trees begin to pierce through
the ruins.
When these trees come to maturity, they die
and discharge a rich soil — or humus — that
corrodes the buildings and allows plants to
take root once more.
Once a sufficient number of Black Trees die,
the labyrinth gives way to a vast forest.
The forest gradually engulfs the continent,
and all creatures who fail to adapt disappear.
No humans remain by this point, and the monsters
of the maze begin new lives treading the green
corridors of the forest.
Underneath the canopy, they live carefully
so as not to incur the silent wrath of the
trees.
For this forest — simply called ‘The Humus’
— is actually a single being.
Interconnected by a web of roots, all trees
and plants of the Humus are governed by a
single intelligence.
Within the never-ending forest, one can only
hear the whispers of the furtive assemblies
held by birds and tiny rodents.
For the world is green and wild once more.
The scars of the Labyrinth and the Cry fade
away, becoming less than a memory.
And for another eternity, a garden blooms
not seen since the first days of the Moon.
Yet as we hurtle towards the end of time,
this paradise cannot endure.
Eventually, the Humus slowly dissolves, the
trees whitening before dissipating into dust…
Once the last grove vanishes, a desert covers
the world.
The desert left by the Humus is breached with
temporal rifts, out of step which strange
roaming beings from the birthplace of dreams.
In places, time has crystalized, forming shapes
that echo and joyously prance in the air.
Abstract beings like Living Lines and The
Time-Altering Ones flicker in and out of existence.
For time is no long grounded by the roots
of the trees, and in this shifting realm of
dreams, nothing can exist for more than a
brief moment.
Yet the Humus, sensing that their time was
coming, has left their mark in this desert.
Their egg, carefully wrapped in a cocoon of
moss and lichen, hatches into a shapeless
being.
Here at the end of time, beyond rust and humus,
the being sits and contemplates the void.
For how long do they stay there, alone, surrounded
by only the time wanderers and the few abstract
beings that occasionally flicker into existence?
We cannot say.
For such things are not for us to know…
In some respects, Rust and Humus is a story
where everything eventually disappears, dies
or is forgotten.
But like a tool turning to rust, or dead leaves
becoming humus, after the end of one system,
a new one emerges.
Equal parts melancholy and hopeful, the saga
offers many other moments I wasn’t able
to cover, and you can read the entire story
from start to end using the links in the description.
If you found this narrative as fascinating
as I did, I encourage you to follow and support
Lucas Roussel, who is working on a massive
follow-up to the project that will reveal
more of this incredible universe.
Once again, links are down below.
And as always, thanks for watching.
If you enjoyed this entry, please lend your
support and like, subscribe, and hit the notification
icon to stay up to date on all things Curious.
See you in the next video.